Welcome to another Zoom call.
Number of questions came in, so let's get started right away on the questions.
A reminder to if you do order labs from us that if you want to go over those labs, make sure you call and make an appointment.
So the first reminder is make sure you use the members site for all the announcements. I try to post things on their.
This things change your updates or anything new.
If you order labs, you want to go over them, please call Marie or Angie or wherever it's in the phone, making a point with me to go over them.
We don't call and do that because a lot of people don't need to go over their labs. They're just ready and read labs. A lot of labs are self explanatory.
We don't ever want to come across as like we're pushing you to do something or spend money that you don't need to spend so we just don't do that.
You need to call it says that elsewhere on the member site too that if you run labs, throw us, make sure you call and ask the only time we'll do that is your initial labs is what we'll call you.
But if you order labs through the lab store, you'll get a copy of it and then we'll go from there.
Also remember there's a 5% discount on supplements if you order through a subscription.
And if you need brands like ortho molecular, biotic research or anything you don't see in our store, you're looking for something we can get it most the time.
And so just call the store number or call the main number and radio will put you through to the store.
Okay, thank you guys know everything else. You'll see on the member site this information about check checking blood glucose.
And somebody asked a question about it so I won't talk anymore about it until we get to that question.
Remember to use the blog posts too.
And remember that some of the blogs on the blog post might be 10 years old and I've written 10 years ago and new data may super seed that.
Okay, first question.
What do you think of methylene blue, methylene blue? Well, it's better than silent green.
Oh, sorry. Okay, methylene blue is.
So I think this person is asking, what do you think about off label use of methylene blue?
So methylene blue is.
Is used really to treat a disease that has to do with the hemoglobin's ability to carry oxygen.
There's a specific to disease. I think it's a.
Metham.
Methamoglobemia or something like that where the person can't carry oxygen methylene blue at its dosage. That's what it was approved for.
So using it off label at using it off label at the full dosage can be a problem for some people because it increases.
The hemoglobin's ability to carry oxygen, but also a side effect of it it increases serotonin levels of the brain.
So methylene blue I know is really pushed by Dr. Mercola. Now he's using it at lower dose, I believe.
So it's an off label use of methylene blue because it increases oxygenation to the tissues.
He thinks it increase, you know, and there's.
I believe it probably does increase the.
Vitocoundary is ability to get oxygen there by increasing your ability to make ATP so you will have more energy.
It can help with things like that.
The problem is if you have a defect in the genes in the biopter in pathway, you may make too much serotonin.
You may have these what are called serotonin surges with it, which can very dangerous.
You can have serotonin surges with people with defects in the biopter in pathway, even by taking methyl groups.
So a lot of people are taking five methyl tetrahedral folate or methylcobolamine in high doses because they have an MTHFR gene defect.
So they think they need to take high doses of methyl folate or they've been told by their nature path very incorrectly that they should be taking.
You have a MTHFR defect so you should be taking high doses of methyl folate.
It's the same thing with methylene blue if you're going to take high doses, if you're going to take methylene blue, those it's going to produce a methyl group.
Problem with that methylene blue as a compound does increase oxygenation, but it also gives off a methyl group, which can be a tumor suppressor blocker.
So two bad things about methylene blue with cancer patients.
Number one, it can increase serotonin with anybody, even if you're not a cancer patient in the brain.
That thing about increased serotonin in the brain, I thought increased serotonin was a happy gene, a happy neurotransmitter and it makes you happy.
No, excess serotonin makes you range, makes you angry, excess serotonin can turn you into a crazy bully fighter.
You can go off the handle at the smallest little discharge.
Matter of fact, it's believed that many people that have mass murderers and people that have issues with these school shootings and things.
One of the ideas from a genetic standpoint is they have defects in their biopteran pathway.
You get too many methyl groups, it can cause this range output.
So that's bad for anybody.
The bad thing for cancer patients is that it increases methyl donor groups, which can turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So while it is the craze, methylene blue is kind of a new craze in alternative spectrum to help with people with really low energy, maybe even depression can't seem to, you know, chronic fatigue issues.
And I have no problem with trying to use it for that reason, but you got to go slow because you can cause other issues.
So methylene blue is used to increase oxygenation of the tissues, therefore alternative practitioners and let's use it a little low doses.
And we can help people with chronic fatigue, but you have to look at the biopteran pathway genes.
If you do have gene defects of the biopteran pathway, you can create excess serotonin levels, which can be deadly at high levels.
And at at medium high levels will cause rage issues.
And that's the serious condition. I remember having a patient years ago where she just did a genetic review and I was talking to her on the phone about her genetics and she had a lot of defects in the biopteran pathways.
And she was taking methyl groups from another practitioner was telling her to take methyl tetraheader folate.
And I said, I can pretty much tell you what your personality trait is and her inner husband or other photo I said, I bet you have times where you just lose your temper and you scream at your kids and then you go in the bedroom and you cry and you go, what in the world is wrong with me?
And that's what happens when your serotonin levels bounce way high in the brain and you have these episodes of elevated serotonin in the brain.
She started crying in the phone, well, I never made that same mistake with the patient again, because her husband then said, well, just this morning she threw a plate at the wall and put a hole in the sheet rock.
And because you can literally look at a person genetics with the biopteran pathway and if they're on the wrong supplements, that could be very dangerous.
So methylene blue is a metal donor and that can cause those issues here to be careful with that.
So you have to be careful with off label use of drugs.
And you have to be careful with what's use of nutritional supplements as well, just because somebody's pushing them for something does not mean that they're good for you number one.
And it does not mean they're good for cancer patients in general number two.
And it doesn't mean that these people that are pushing these things are looking at the big picture number three.
So with the onset of Instagram and everybody trying to be a nutritional hero out there and gate as many followers as possible, they're posting a lot of stuff that are a lot of kind of untruths.
And these people are, you know, maybe they're not doctors, maybe they're not looking at the total physiology, maybe they're just trying to gain followers, you just have to be careful out there.
Just be careful. That's why I look at your supplements that I take you guys off some stuff because most of the time, a lot of people start with us and they're on a lot of mental groups, they're on copper, which stimulates cancer growth, they're on things that stimulate growth of cancer in general with cancer patients and they shouldn't be doing that.
And I've had people come back to me and say, I talked to my natural method, she can't figure out why you took me off this because I have this defect, well, they're not looking at the big picture.
I don't want to insult anybody's intelligence and I'm not always right by any stretch of the imagination and I'll gladly be proven wrong on anything.
But I just want you to know my opinion, I spent way too much time in this question.
Last week, also someone asked what to do for kinkersawers.
I thought it was mentioned, it was worth mentioning that I have had tremendous success with my cold source running the kinkersawer cold source program on the right.
Thank you for that reminder because I did not say that.
So here you're correcting me appreciate that so I always have everybody to go to the right first.
And here I did not do that in answering that question.
So the benefit of going to the right first before you even go by rising for your kinkersawers or calcium lactate, the two things that I suggested.
You said you already have it and you don't need to always add chemistry to it.
You can use frequency. So here's a person who uses the kinkersawer cold source program and this should be for everything.
I have an infection run the right for infections. I have this and run the right for that.
That should be your first go to thank you for the person who said this because it's a good reminder for everybody, including myself.
Not only is the right stop the cold source from getting bad.
I don't nearly get them as nearly as often mine are stress related. Yes, because stress member.
I said cold source are because something changes the pH of your cell in your mouth changes.
And then that gives the chance for the herpes.
The simplex tend to come right down the trigeminal nerve and cause a pulsar.
So stress can change the pH. You also can eat citrus and all sorts of things so stress major player and that last week you answered my question about leg cramps on the keto diet.
So the person asked the question if you didn't listen to that recording last week.
They were the keto diet and started having leg cramps really bad and I mentioned that I'm trying to figure through it in my head.
My version of the keto diet is heavy on the leafy grains but lackey the bride and vegetables, you said.
The fact that this diet puts me in circumstances that creates my cramps really makes me doubt the overall healthiness of this diet.
I would agree that you do have to question the healthiness of a diet when it's causing you side effects right.
But you might be doing it for other reasons maybe your glucose is like way too high.
Maybe you have diabetes and you're trying to break that cycle of diabetes and heal yourself membranes and get your glucose way down.
But you know there's other reasons for doing it maybe you have you know rain answer and you're going out of ketogenic diet and you can live with the side effects of maybe too little minerals and you need to deal with that maybe by taking supplements so there may be reasons to do it.
This person, I know what they're dealing with they could probably drop this diet so I would agree.
I need a 10 day trip to Ireland of wild in September.
So right off the bat I'm pretty sure you have to take me with you.
What do you mean it's this question is going to take me with just kidding.
I was contemplating adding extra days before and after I took a step in my trip.
I take because I have no idea other than the fact that I still feel the lump in my breast of the progression or not progression on my cancer.
I don't want to be foolish and miss too many days of my detox and the right is I would say and we mentioned before that you know taking the right overseas maybe you know an issue going through customs and stuff.
I probably wouldn't do that.
And I don't think this person is planning on bringing their right from their trip to Ireland.
And they're concerned that 10 days of 14 days or whatever it's going to be might be a long time without it.
I'm two years post diagnosis and I haven't had a scan or sense by MRI in August of last year.
Another MRI is out because of the GAD GAD is short for Gantelidium, which is a die used as a contrast die in the MRI this person gets.
I thought pet skin might be most useful.
I could it could tell me if the lump is still cancer or has become from a product by product.
It also would tell me if there's any metastasis after two years I spoke with my colleges about this after having not seen her for the interview two years.
Having refused the medication at my first appointment with her and she said a pet scan was notably unreliable picking up active disease of the breast tissue.
Oh gosh, I would totally disagree with her because if you don't have, you know, highly metabolic.
If it's become fiberotic, it's not going to be highly metabolic and it's not going to light up.
I on the pet's get I don't understand what she's saying with that.
That makes absolutely zero sense to me.
So a pet scan will light up the term for it when you have highly metabolic tissue.
So that's why it'll pick up metastasis and it always picks up the primary cancer if the primary cancer is growing.
So if there is no growth, it's a lot of dead tissue, a lot of the chronic cells.
If I product tissue is this person mentioned, it's not going to light up on test kit.
That would be a that would be a good test to do.
But she also said insurance will cover it unless I'm stage three or more.
I was stage one B at diagnosis or I have symptoms of metastasis, possibly, which I don't.
She's pushing me for a mammogram and ultrasound plus biopsy.
Not interested in compressing the tumor with a mammogram, not convinced that the ultrasound radiation is harmless.
And I don't want to puncture the tumor again.
I would totally agree.
The other thing about, I mean, I think that the ultrasound would be the least invasive because the pet scan is not not invasive, still using radiation.
And I think it's much more invasive than ultrasound.
So I'd be more up to say ultrasound.
The negative is, is the ultrasound is not going to differentiate whether it's my erotic tissue.
Or it's some active cancer, which is going to show a mass.
So that's the negative.
Not interested.
I'm just stuck.
Never know what's going on.
Or am I just stuck? What's the wisest decision?
Well, I know you, I know you're feeling great.
Personally, I'd say is go on the trip.
Don't even worry about test to do.
If you want to get some objective testing, you can run tumor markers.
If, if me say that, if your answer is, I've done two markers, they don't show up.
But then I would just go on the trip.
I just go enjoy yourself.
You, why are you trying to get better in the first place?
So you could do this kind of stuff.
So go enjoy yourself.
That can be the best thing.
You don't remember so much of healing is between our ears.
So going at a joy life.
You're not neglecting what you ought to do.
You are doing what you ought to do.
50 weeks of the year so that you could go do this and have this be something you ought to do also.
So have no guilt. Go enjoy yourself.
And just have a fantastic time.
And I think that will be so good for you in so many ways.
As anyone ever had any trouble entering a foreign country.
In this case, Canada with smoothie ingredients like medicinal mushrooms,
Miracle mix, number one.
Green's first course to work.
That's a good question.
We do ship to Canada all the time.
Canada is one country we typically don't have trouble getting supplements into.
I do believe Canada is becoming more and more covetistic.
That goes without saying, but we have not had trouble shipping to Canada.
Up at the time of this recording.
So I would say, well, let people chime in.
I have not heard anybody have trouble with that.
But let's have if anybody did.
Please chime in.
Is there anything something else I could do for my.
Well, Angel Carcinoma besides the nightly rifing supplements.
A daily coffee and I'm also trying to follow a healthy diet is working because I do.
Yes, I would say because I looked at this question before I would say.
The other thing that I would do if you're still struggling with it where this cancer is at the bio duct.
And the goal letter.
I would say the hyperthermia, the localized hyperthermia.
So.
Give Marie a call and set up a time that we can chat.
So that's what I would do with.
And we I'll go into detail with it when we talk.
You suggested that I call regarding my lab.
I just want to give you more information.
I lost a lot of blood during surgery in mid-April.
Down to almost seven.
Seven.
I mean, they're human.
But I did not want to receive any blood.
Also, I have a juicy and eating mostly vegetarian diet since then.
But just recently after lab started eating meat, do you still think I should set up a call?
Well, you don't need to if you feel like you're getting more energy.
So human global down to seven and not receiving any blood.
That's a, that's a big uphill battle that you have to climb and it's doable.
So.
But it's going to take time to build up your blood.
I'm talking about.
It's more difficult to do on a vegetarian diet.
So while you're eating meat, you're going to help build your human globe and much quicker.
And have a better chance of doing that.
So no, we don't have to set up a call.
If you don't want to, I would like to have you spend.
If you're concerned about cost and such, I just get another blood test.
So get regular blood tests.
If your doctor will do it, it'll cover under your insurance.
Every week, if you can't, certainly you're having a heap of low, but of almost seven warrants or insurance to pay for weekly blood tests.
If you're like not getting a pain under insurance at all.
And the doctor's charging more, you can get those run through our lab store for probably less expensive, but.
Just make sure you send me the labs when you have them done.
In reference to the glucose meter, the glucometer on your site, you have an asterisk at the bottom that says it's not appropriate for blood cancer.
So here's the question I talked about before.
The glucometer is not what's not important for blood cancer, but just checking your glucose on a weekly basis is not important for the leukemias.
I have to change this because the when I say blood cancers, I'm really talking about the leukemias.
And because most leukemias are not fed by glucose.
Now it's still important to keep your glucose, you know, in a healthy range, whether you have cancer or not, whether you have leukemia or not.
But it's more important to have your glucose in a healthy range if you have a solid tumor.
So that is a lymphoma. I talked to somebody about this the other day.
Well, lymphoma is technically a blood cancer, but lymphoma is kind of that in between cancer because there's it becomes a solid cancer.
So lymphoma is kind of leukemia that has become a solid, solid tumor.
So lymphoma, yes, you can feed a locova lymphoma through the glycolysis pathway.
We need through the breakdown of glucose, so it's beneficial to keep your glucose at the lowest level as possible.
But if you have a leukemia, is it is important to check your blood glucose on a regular basis?
It is as it would be if you had a solid tumor, the answer is no, in my opinion.
It's important if you have a solid tumor, whether it be brain cancer, breast cancer, you know, any cancer other than the leukemias, then it's important to check your blood glucose when you can.
You know, a lot of you guys are getting a CBC and a complete metabolic panel on a monthly basis and your blood glucose is better than the 80s.
Well, you don't need a glucometer then, you know, but for those who I haven't been doing that, and I do want to, you know, I'm trying to keep a really good diet. So I want to, you know, check my glucose levels, then then get a little glucometer like this, they're really handy.
The question on the clinic, computer testing were where to buy, I understand at the bottom of it says it's not appropriate. Okay, so that's what I mean by that.
It's beneficial for everybody. It's not as important for leukemia patients.
All right, the six drops of biosided by husband takes seems to make his throat burn. Could it, could he mix it with one ounce of water instead of taking it straight?
Answer yes, actually you can mix it with even more water if it helps you can put it in with a smoothie. That's fine. You can put it in.
So you could dilute it any way you want to dilute it. However, you need to, it's a strong herbs in biosided and it can make your throat burn definitely.
So do it take any way you need to take that.
I woke up at 530 this morning, freezing and disoriented and threw up my temperature with 104 Tim husband gave me one Ivan Proven brought my temperature down to 100 fairly quickly.
It stayed down a little 100 on its own, but it's now climbing again 101.8 a few minutes ago, my main symptoms are chills fatigue and headache.
I call my ecologist requested a blood test. I emailed those to you. My part was installed for weeks ago.
It has been newly sore over the weekend, but shows no obvious signs of infection.
What do you think? So I screen shot at the lamps that this person said because I think there's a lesson in this.
So here's this is a CBC with the virtual. So CBC is white blood cell and red blood cell hemoglobin, all the breakdowns of the red cell line platelets and then a breakdown of the white blood cell line in percentage and total absolute count here.
So we want to look at this. Now different lamps have different normal values, some normal values of white blood cells are 4.5 to 11 like this, other lamps like be 4.0 to 10.
But quite honestly, anything really over six, you think you have something going on. So white blood cell 7.1.
There's something going on right off the back. Now we're going to go back, come back to the white blood cell in just a second.
Let's look at the rest of this test red blood cells 4.1 died just on the edge of low. So that is by definition anemia.
Even when you have low red blood cells, even close to low, you have anemia. Now what will happen with anemia is that that you'll have other of these red blood cell components be out of line as well over time.
Now all of these, the hemoglobin is still with a normal range, hematocrit, the mean cell volume and all these other components are still with a normal range.
So that tells you that either a, this is an early edemia, which is good. You know, you don't want a more chronic edemia.
Or be this is what's called an acute edemia. So if the person has acute blood loss. So if the person has acute blood loss, let's say they just started having a bleeding ulcer yesterday.
And they have black stools, black tary stools. That's what happened if you had a bleeding ulcer. And you can have low red blood cells with no other other red blood cell components be abnormal.
Or if you have an early edemia. So let's take a step back. There's different types of anemia. There's anemia of a chronic disease, which is the most common edemia sound found with cancer patients.
So the most common type of edemia found with cancer patients is called anemia of chronic disease. That's the, that's the technical name for it.
And you will see low red blood cells. You'll see low Hebrew globin, quite often.
He medicate can be low. The mean cell volume and MCH MCHC will be typically elevated in edemia, chronic disease. And these are components of the red blood cell itself.
The volume of the red blood cell will be enlarged the size, the volume will be enlarged the size as it's measured will be enlarged because it's tried to carry more oxygen.
So that and the red cell with will be elevated typically as well. So that's typically anemia of chronic disease.
And then you could have anemia of B12 deficiency, and that looks a little bit different, and I won't go into that. And then you could have some, you could have a folate, anemia.
So there's different types of anemia that you look for, but almost always with our cancer patients, it's going to be anemia of chronic disease where red blood cells, hemoglobin, hematocrit, maybe suppressed.
And the rest of these are going to be elevated. That's not uncommon at all. So we don't see any of that yet. So that's a good thing for this patient. We have some early anemia going on.
That's certainly not what's causing the fever. Okay. So whatever you have fever, you think of infection. What is causing this fever.
So the medical doctor may look at this and go, I think you're fine because your white blood cell code is still with a normal rage. So this person might have a normal white blood cell code of 4.5.
And that would be, could be normal in this case. If this person has a history of cancer, they can have a normal for them white blood cell code that is suppressed.
You know, 3.0 because they've been dealing with fighting cancer. And now a white blood cell called a 7.1 is highly elevated. So I think 7.1 is elevated anyhow. So then you look at the breakdown of white blood cells. So here's the breakdown of white blood cells.
This person has elevated white blood cells. And I would define this as elevated white blood cells. If they have elevated neutrophils think that it's a bacterial infection.
This person doesn't have elevated neutrophils. Neutrophils come is with a normal rage right in the middle. So it's probably not a bacterial infection. If they have elevated white blood cell come side of infection fever nausea blah blah blah.
And they have elevated lymphocytes. That's this right here limb percentage.
Oh, no, that's not it either. But if they had elevated lymphocytes think viral infection viral infection. If they have elevated eacidophils that's EOS right here. Oh, that's what this person has.
Think allergy. So this is just in general. So elevated eacidophils think allergy. So benefit this person's absolute lymphocytes code is actually low.
So why would they have a low lymphocyte code and possible elevated white blood cells. You know, if the other thing that tells you is that for them, without this fever, their white blood cell code is probably lower than 4.5. The fever caused it to be up to 7.1.
So eacidophils allergy possibly. Here's the absolute eacidophil count is as elevated as well. So what could cause an allergy could be something they ate to the couldn't have an acute sensitivity acute reaction to something that would not necessarily be out of the question could be food poisoning of something like that.
That's what you think of with a blunt test like this.
I would not think that it has to do with an infected port infected port you think of bacterial infection and you'd see an elevated neutrophil count.
Okay, some other questions.
Okay, Ireland here. So Ireland is 10 days looking at attacking it on up to 14 additional days. Perhaps does that seem a little too much.
No, as long as you don't drink too much beer over there in the pubs. That's the only thing.
For the low iron person, Hannah Kroger used to say that taking molasses could increase iron. That's kind of the ever heard of that. Maybe juicy beats. I'd agree with both those things.
So if you have low iron, so I don't know what the low iron person you're talking about the red blood cell count here. So you can have anemia of iron deficiency. That's another type of anemia.
So I am not a big fan unless you have very serious anemia of doing using iron for cancer patients because iron can be gobbled up can be a fuel for cancer.
So you could use food based things like juicy beats. That's the thing that I have always recommended and you could use some molasses that can be helpful to some good, good comments there.
My genetic test showed that my cancer is fed by glucose. You suggested a keto-like diet. Please explain this diet more in terms of amounts of meat.
Vegetables, grains, cooked, or raw still feel confusion to what to eat.
Well, it is confusing on what to eat because everybody's different. And if you want a full ketogenic diet, the problem with that is you're not going to know what to eat because you typically have to stay away from dairy too because dairy, even if that isn't a driver for your cancer, it can quickly become a driver for your cancer for people who are doing a ketogenic diet because typically ketogenic diets are very high in dairy.
And then your cancer can easily switch to becoming fat on dairy. So you're doing a ketogenic diet that's low in dairy. What are you going to eat? Just meat. It's difficult. You need some other things. So that's why I always suggest a keto-like diet and you have to kind of watch, you know, where you're getting enough food to stay, have energy, getting enough carbohydrates to have energy.
So you're not going to be able to eat a lot of meat, but still not spiky to your glucose. So anybody that's that is their cancer is mainly fed by glucose.
This right here is your friend because this will this is your answer to everything. So if you could keep your glucose levels in the 80s perfect world in the 70s, you are really going to shut down the fuel source of your cancer.
And that's even if boy, by it is, I woke up yesterday morning, it was 75 and you know, I ate two pieces of toast yesterday and some oatmeal. Well, then more power to you. There's some people that can do that.
So that's not even close to being a ketogenic diet. If you're eating grains like that, but it's the goal ultimately is to get your glucose, your glucose, you know, fasting state down, you know, 75 or below, but realistically that I've said this over and over again that, you know, a lot of people, you know, that are not 22 years old.
But it's not a genetic diet. So don't look at the Instagrammers that are bragging about how they've lost all their weight and they look buff as a weight lifter and doing a ketogenic diet is the answer.
They're also in their 20s or 30s and that's all they do is work out every day.
And then you stick for most people who've lived life and you could actually harm yourself, trying to match a person, you know, like that, don't compare yourself one to another, we're committed not to do that.
The goal is to get your glucose levels down. That's the ultimate goal in a ketogenic diet as well. I don't advocate using a ketosis trying to get into ketosis unless a person has
a glioblastoma or something like that, which is a brain cancer.
So getting into ketosis isn't the important thing getting your blood glucose down is the important thing.
Remember, you could work so hard on a ketogenic diet to get yourself into ketosis and stay in ketosis.
And if you're doing it for cancer reasons, your cancer could easily flip, we fed by something else that you're eating a lot of.
So don't work that hard on that, just just just measuring your glucose and try to get that as low as reasonably possible.
If my fever nausea is an allergic response, what should I do about it?
Well, if it is an allergic response, then there's all you could do for that is to look at what possibly could be the allergen.
There's other things that could be causing it, of course, and looking at, like, okay, let me read the rest of the question.
My college wants me to go to the emergency room, we get a chest x-ray, blood cultures, urine cultures in a respiratory panel.
You know, quite honestly, I'm excited to hear your oncologist be so diligent about diggy to this because you really get that.
So if your fever continues and you continue to feel really bad, then diggy did it, getting a chest x-ray because they're concerned about pneumonia.
So that's what they're looking for, getting other blood cultures, urine cultures in a respiratory panel to make sure there isn't some type of other infection in your lungs would be the right thing to do.
Also, remember that having a fever, you know, 100 and 102, well, that's not pleasant whatsoever to go through that can put a person in remission.
So that is literally what at least toxins are, is that they gave people a toxic culture of bacterial viruses that were a mixture of different ones, not enough of anything to cause serious deadly disease, but enough to cause a very high fever state.
When they put these people in high fever states, their cancers went into remission and just saw a news report of Cleveland clinic, or was it Mayo clinic a couple of years ago that was experimenting with this new therapy, I'm doing the exact same thing that FDA outlawed in the 1950s, which was using a culture mix of toxins to give to people so that they would produce a fever state.
A fever state and that fever state would thereby stimulate an immune response to kill the cancer and put people into remission funny, huh?
So when they do it that's okay, but what an alternative doctor does it, well, it's a voodoo.
So I'm not saying you should just not investigate the reason why a person has a fever continue to investigate by all means if your oncologist is willing to do those things, I would follow up and do those things.
But if it calms down and settles down that I wouldn't follow up and do anything about it probably at all because it probably was poison or something like that, but if it isn't, then, you know, least look at that doesn't mean that you should just run off and take a bunch of talent all to get your fever down to normal either because all you're doing is artificially lower your fever you're not allowed your body to kill any type of thing that's going on in the first place so you actually could be hurting yourself doing that.
No, you don't want your fever to ever get too high because that can cause damage to your brain cells.
I am waking up in the night with pins and needles in my fingers and it mostly goes away, but during the day, I'm still having a bit of numbness in my fingers.
When my chiropractor adjusts my neck, I feel it in my fingers, so I figure it must be my neck going out, but his adjustments aren't holding any suggestion.
Number one, I'm very, very role chiropractic for cancer patients, but make sure your chiropractor is doing low force adjustments.
Just a lot of chiropractors, you know, what is how to put this?
A lot of chiropractors are, you know, think that a chiropractic adjustment is going to cure everything and you just need to get adjusted and they ignore the fact that you have cancer that possibly might have the testicist at the testicized to the spine.
And then an adjustment could fracture a vertebrae quite easily and cause serious, serious damage.
So, A, make sure the chiropractor is doing low force adjustment, hopefully activator.
B, make sure the chiropractor is getting adequate x-rays.
And see, remember that even if the chiropractor took x-rays and says, I don't see any metastasis to the spine, that the simple radiological fact that you have to have over 50% bold loss to see bold loss on x-ray.
So say that again, if you don't have, if you only have 40% bold loss from metastasis to the spine, you may not see it until it's over 50%.
So just because they take an x-ray and it looks clean does not, in my opinion, give any chiropractor the right to do manual adjustments to your neck.
So just be careful of that.
If they're really a gentle adjuster to a gentle, gentle manual adjustments, that's fine, but it concerns me that when they adjust you, this phrase concerned me, when you said when my chiropractor adjusts my neck, I feel it in my fingers.
That concerns me a little bit.
So just be careful of that.
Honestly, most likely the pins and needles in your fingers have to do.
Waking up in the morning with that has to do with poor sleeping posture, your neck is in a position where it's kind of throwing your.
If you're in a place, think about getting a chiropractor chiropractic pillow from your chiropractor that will hold your neck and place a little bit better.
Give it your neck support, you need to have a 35 to 45 degree curve from a lateral picture in your neck.
And if you don't have that, if your neck is cranked up at all, you're going to be impinging the spinal nerves and causing you know the neuropathy that way.
This could be definitely could be a structural problem.
And you know, if your adjustments aren't holding, then you have to look at, well, why aren't my adjustments holding, hopefully you're going to a car parger that's addressing these kind of things.
Your bones don't move by themselves, they move by action of the muscles and they're held together by action of the ligaments.
So, you know, weakness in ligaments is most commonly caused from damage, you know, a whiplash of some kind, damaging the ligaments weakness in the muscles has to do with, you know,
muscle contusion or muscle stretch or muscle damage of some kind and it can be just chronic damage from poor posture.
So, look at your posture, hopefully your car parger is doing some origin insertion work on your scalines on your,
your super spinoid muscles, you know, trying to work on those muscles that are supposed to be holding your vertebrae in place.
But, you know, maybe find a car parger that does more kinesiology applied kinesiology work that can do muscle work on that to work on the reason why those are going out of place.
Do you know about the EE system?
You'll have to elaborate. I don't know what the EE system is.
So, if you could tell me that maybe I don't know that acronym.
He is using some kind of activator on man neck and when I, he does I feel it by fingers.
But then I would look at that's good. Glad he's doing that.
Have a work on the muscles that hold the neck in place, hold the vertebrae in place.
Have a work, you know, deal with posture, deal with sleeping posture.
You, you know, think about those kind of things. You can also use a tens unit.
There's no counter indications with cancer with a tens unit that can really help with muscles.
You have F can be really helpful with your muscles.
Other electro therapy can be really helpful with your muscles and go back to this question right here.
Don't forget to do the right on some different programs for muscles and paid and such too.
So think about using frequencies energy enhancement system.
I do not know what that is.
The top of my head.
Let me, let me look it up real quick, EE system. Here it is.
Okay. Yeah, I'd have to look at more of what they're used.
What they're calling the energy enhancement system and looks like they're using.
Looks like different bracelets they have.
So, yeah, I have to look at what they're doing.
They talk a lot about scalar fields and bio scalar residents steps.
There's a lot of stuff out there that talks about that.
Some is hypercelling different things that.
Do nothing. Some might have very good benefits.
So I don't want to knock what anybody else is doing.
If it works for a person, then that's great.
As long as it.
You know, doesn't have any.
Negative connotations.
I don't think there's anything wrong with any of them.
Is a chiropractic pillow one of those that sort of has a curve at the bottom.
I sleep on my side a lot.
Just make sure if you're sleeping on your side that your spine is straight.
Just think of anatomy.
Your spine, you know, looking front to back should be straight.
If it isn't that's called a scoliosis.
If you could look at yourself from the side, you should have a cervical curve of 35 to 45 degrees.
If you could say what's your thoracic scoy the other way and say what's your lumbar scoy the same way as your cervical spine.
And you know, if you're, if your head is tilted forward, you have a forward head posture, you're going to have a decreased cervical curve that's going to cause straight.
If you could look like a masculine, the scale needs the upper traps and your super spin on us and you know, all your sits muscles, your shoulders.
You could have pinching going on in your nerves to your arms, your cervical nerves going down your arms can be an issue.
So massage can help with that as well.
Having somebody help you with your posture, using the tens unit using ice can help.
Authorities how to hold can help.
So getting somebody that does more physical work on your body can be helpful going to a physical therapist can be helpful.
So any other questions.
Okay.
Thanks for being on.
We will talk to you next week.
Remember, if you need a personal conversation, you can call the schedule a time with me anytime.
And I feel really terrible.
What should I do about the fever?
Just when I mentioned again, eat monitoring your fever.
You don't want it to get up above 104.
You do want to investigate, you know, to the best your ability, what is causing it.
But you don't want to necessarily take a fever of 100 and what are 102 and use medication to lower it when that could actually be beneficial to have that fever for your cancer.
And when people get really, really bad flu before, get really, really sick, having a fever, high fever for multiple days and it literally said their cancer in a state of remission.
And they wanted remission because of that.
So I'm not saying that you shouldn't investigate a fever.
You don't necessarily need when you have when your body is eliciting symptoms, it doesn't always mean that you have to change those symptoms.
Sometimes those symptoms are a purpose and the fever is a purpose to kill something.
Sometimes if it's an allergy, if there's nothing to kill, because it's not a living organism.
So the fever can last longer.
But sometimes if it's a bacterial infection or a viral infection, the fever has a very distinct purpose to kill it.
And we go and we artificially reduce the temperature of our body by taking it over the counter medication.
And then your body's like screaming at you like what is this blazes are you doing.
I'm trying to increase the your core temperature to kill off this infection is you're you're fighting against me.
Of course, you don't want to let the fever get too high, but you also want to recognize it's your body's normal response to something.
Again, there's nothing wrong with going in and getting a chest X ray, make sure you don't have any, you know, crazy infection in your lung.
And that's what your doctor is concerned about because of the port and the location of the port could have introduced an infection in the lung.
So there's nothing wrong with doing that.
Is ibuprofen okay to keep it under 104 if that's what's working to keep it under 104, but I can't really comment on ibuprofen because it's a medication.
And it has side effects too, so.
But if what's working for you to keep it there, then I don't see any problem with that.
Alright, thank you so much and we'll see you guys next week.